the claim against Supreme Court nominee
Brett Kavanaugh that he committed some
kind of sexual assault while a student
in high school has metastasized into
something different something ugly and
something threatening to all of us we've
learned remarkably little about Brett
Kavanaugh or Kristine Ford in the past
week despite a lot of words on their
behalf the facts of the case are still
sparse and they're murky but we've
learned a disturbing amount about the
left and what it's willing to do in
order to maintain control of this
country watch a clip from today in which
New York senator Kirsten Gillibrand
explained why she knows Brett Kavanaugh
is guilty watch I believed her because
she's telling the truth she is asking
the FBI to investigate her claims she's
asking for that kind of review that
investigative work that oversight that
accountability because she's telling the
truth someone who is lying does not ask
the FBI to investigate their claims who
is not asking the FBI to investigate
these claims the White House
dr. Cavanaugh excuse me judge Kavanaugh
has not asked to have the FBI review
these claims is that the is that the
reaction of an innocent person
it is not so try to ignore the yelling
there and the theatrics and the pure
demagoguery of the moment and focus
instead on Kirsten Gillibrand reasoning
to the extent that there is any quote I
believe her because she's telling the
truth or put another way it's true
because it is now in logic class they
call the circular reasoning which isn't
actually reasoning at all instead it's
simply a demand that you believe
something because someone else is
asserting it children talk this way you
think you a senator would be embarrassed
to but it's the second part of
Gillibrand statement that you ought to
pay attention to because it's scary
Kavanagh hasn't called for yet another
FBI investigation into himself
therefore senator Gillibrand says he did
it is that the reaction of an innocent
person she thunders it is not well not
since the McCarthy era almost 70 years
ago have lawmakers talked like this in
this country unless you call for an FBI
investigation of yourself you're guilty
of a crime even Joe McCarthy him
never said anything like that he was too
reckless even for him
and now one of the Democratic Party's
leading presidential candidates casually
drops the line at a press conference in
the media hardly notice so apparently
that's the new standard in Washington
okay well let's start with Kirsten
Gillibrand Gillibrand was a friend of
Harvey Weinstein's here's a picture of
the two of them together Weinstein has
been credibly accused of rape d kirsten
gillibrand know about Weinstein sexual
assaults
was she an accessory to them we've asked
those questions before on this show but
we never got an answer why isn't
Gillibrand demanded an FBI investigation
into herself to clear that up is that
the reaction of an innocent person by
her standards it's not so bring on the
FBI let me interview Kirsten Gillibrand
under oath maybe surprise her at her
home at dawn with a search warrant and
while they're at it they should take a
very close look at her relationship with
Bill Clinton another accused rapist no
doubt the senator will beg for an
investigation into that - assuming she's
innocent if she hesitates press charges
this is lunatic sober liberals
understand that it is Democrats don't
want Brett Kavanaugh on the court
because they disagree with them and
that's understandable by the way they're
angry that the Republican Senate refused
to vote on Barack Obama's last Supreme
Court nominee Merrick garland that's
understandable - but what's happening
now is dangerous in a way that has
nothing to do with politics it's a
threat to the civil liberties of every
American no matter who you voted for in
extremism has exploded on the left and
nobody is trying to contain it here's
one particularly jarring example of that
this is Congressman John Garamendi of
California we know him well he's one of
the few House Democrats willing to come
on this show we don't usually agree with
Garamendi but we've always found him to
be a decent and reasonable person always
here's what he just said about the
Cavanaugh allegations women across this
nation should be outraged at what these
white men senators are doing to this
woman the senators the male senators who
control that committee are playing the
game as old as an assault and that is
the woman's the accused the woman is at
fault wait a second what is the race of
specific senators have to do with any of
this should we be angry at them because
of their skin color so we
distrust them more are they inherently
less fair or less decent because of the
way they look
Garamendi is implying exactly that so
how is that different or better than
anything George Wallace ever said well
it's not except that suddenly this filth
is everywhere so you hardly even notice
it the last thing this country needs
right now is more racial division
Democrats are pushing it anyway they're
using allegations that have literally
nothing to do with race at all but
splitting the country into tiny warring
groups is useful to them it helps them
maintain their power and so they're
happy to do it men against women black
against white divide and conquer
whatever it takes
in the end it's unlikely that we'll ever
know conclusively what happened between
Brett Kavanaugh and Christine Ford 36
years ago if anything at all but it's
crystal clear what's happening right now
this is a power grab it is hurting the
country destroying our centuries-old
traditions of justice and empowering
morons and demagogues we ought to shut
it down right now and yet and this is
late-breaking news just seconds before
airtime we learned that this may go on
and on Republicans on the hill tonight
are considering delaying the hearing
scheduled for Monday at this point Brett
Kavanaugh will be testifying by himself
to some future date because of the rules
of the Senate that would push back the
vote on Kavanagh by at least a week if
not more which is of course the whole
point to drag the country through this
pointless charade this circus which it
divides us and hurts us and degrades our
standards of justice simply for
political ends that's where we are